hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and not sure if
you're aware but we're two months away
from the candidates tournament yes the
candidates tournament which it feels
like we just wrapped up the last one
we're two months away from another one
the winner of that tournament does go on
to face magnus carlsen for the world
championship early in 2023 so massive
deal these players have been qualifying
for the last couple of years i want to
do a spotlight video on each of them
some of them are new faces some of them
are old faces but i want to let you know
how they qualified then go over one of
their recent games so you have an idea
of their playing style we'll talk about
how that lines up against magnus carlsen
so you'll be all ready to go for the
candidates tournament
today's spotlight is on ali reza he's
the 18 year old phenom if you haven't
heard of him he is a phenomenal player
he's already the number two rated player
in the world which is crazy at 18 years
old he was the fastest player ever to
get to the rating of 2800
beat out magnus carlsen for the fastest
to that
and he qualified because in the end of
2021 in november he won the fid grand
swiss tournament this was a tournament
some of the top players in the world
there was 108 of them
and he was one of the top two now
fabiano caruana also was able to qualify
because fabiano was number two but he
did lose out to ali reza so fantastic
fantastic player madness carlson has
already gone on the books and said he's
not sure if he can get as excited about
playing these world championships
anymore it takes a lot out of him but he
would get excited to play alireza
because he's just a phenom and 18 years
old that would be a massive massive deal
you also have to remember that garrett
kasparov and magnus carlson both 22
years old and they were the two youngest
to ever win alireza would be 19 when he
actually plays madness carlson if he
were to win the candace tournament we
are definitely getting ahead of
ourselves because there's a lot of other
great players in the candace tournament
but let's go ahead and dive in and look
at one of the matches so you have an
idea of his playing style because one
thing i've seen as i analyze his games
he is relentless he can take games that
absolutely look like a draw and he will
push and find a way to put tons of
pressure on his opponent and try to find
a win that is exactly what you want to
see
in the world championship we've seen a
lot of matches at the world championship
that's very drawlish a lot of players
aren't really fighting for a win you
have someone like magnus crossman they
can just grind them in
to submission over time
that's exactly the kind of game plan
that ali reza is looking to
to capitalize on he wants these jolish
games that he can turn into a victory so
i think his playing style would line up
very well
now we are going to look at a game for
molly reza this is from that tournament
he won the grand swiss tournament in
november of 2021 he's playing the white
pieces his opponent playing the black
pieces is grand master ninja basif now i
do want to thank our sponsor skillshare
more from them later in this video so
ali reza starts out with e4
e5 and knight f3 knight c6 and then pawn
d4 so we get into the petrov but we
avoid the main line of knight takes on
e5 d6 forcing the knight to come back
and said
ali reza says you know what let's mix it
up a little bit let's play d4
and then knight takes here and then pawn
takes e5 now this is a line that a lot
of masters play but usually
we see
bishop to
d3
getting the light square bishop involved
into the game preparing to castle on the
king side attacking this knight on e4
but that's not what ali reza's does
instead he takes on e5
and then we have the pawn pushing
forward to d5
knight d2 and then after bishop e7 we
have the exchange right here and then
the queens come off the board
now the thing about this position is
this tends to be a drawless position
anytime you exchange minor pieces and
then you exchange the queens off the
board if both sides are equal in
material it tends to be fairly draws
but
holly reza has different things in store
and he shows how he's able to take a
pretty common game that seems like he
would end up in a drawless position and
is able to attack his opponent
relentlessly and puts them in some
really tough positions
ali reza continues with knight d4 his
knight was under attack from the pawn so
bring this to essential square d4
knight d7 attacking the pawn on e5
bishop f4
controlling the e5 square and also
preparing to castle on the queen side if
he wants to
that comes down to
c5 defending the pawn on e4 also opening
up for the light square bishop to get
involved into the game recognizing that
he can't take the pawn on e5
now castle on the queen's heads you can
start to see hey if we are going to
exchange off queens the knights have
already come off the board at least one
of them
one of the best ways to continue to be
aggressive is to castle on the queen
side hope your opponent castles on the
king side and then both sides can just
throw everything they can at the
opponent's king
now we see pawn c6
then bishop c4 you can see that white's
doing a good job of every single move
they're doing gets another piece
involved into the action they're getting
their pieces developed towards the
center of the board
and they're really starting to line up a
central attack as well as attacking some
of the critical squares the f7 square
one of the weakest squares for black
early on because it's only defended by
the king
black continues with bishop e7 and then
rook e1 so white's got both of his rooks
in the center of the board the rook on
e1 is attacking the pawn on e4
the pawn's only being defended by
the knight on c5 so the next move from
white pretty logical to play b4 anytime
you're attacking a piece and it's
defended by another piece one of your
things you should be looking at is can i
attack the piece that's defending it and
force it away so i can easily take that
piece
so
understanding that's exactly what it's
going to do
black plays pawn to a5 makes a ton of
sense for various reasons one is you
want to block pawn to b4 but you also
want to start throwing everything at the
queen side of white since they've
castled on the queen side they've
already committed the king to that side
and so that's where you want to start
putting all your pressure so a5 is the
most logical move exactly what black
plays now we see h3 now sometimes h3 is
almost a filler move you're not exactly
sure uh what to do so you play h3
stopping your opponent from coming in
but now you know ollie reza has a very
clear
reason to do this he wants his rook on
these central squares he does not want
the bishop coming down to g4 so h3 is
defending that square
pawn two h5
then we see pawn a3
and then bishop to d7 so black still has
the option if he wants to come over here
and castle on the queen side remember
once the queen's exchange the bishop
came back and took on d8 the king did
not take on the eight so there there are
some options depending on if black wants
to hassle on the queen side or on the
king side
before we continue a quick word from our
sponsor skillshare
if you're not familiar with skillshare
it's an online community where you can
take classes on pretty much anything
that you want they always have new
content i just got through going through
one on tick tock it seems like everyone
is on tick tock these days so i thought
i would learn a little bit more about it
i am going to create an account on tick
tock i'm not exactly sure what it's
going to be on if it's chess or math or
the premier league i have some other
interest as well that i may do but this
is very informative to go through step
by step on how to
be successful on tick tock so if you're
curious about skillshare you want to
check it out the first thousand people
that click on the link in the
description below or use my code the
chess website will get a free
month so definitely check that out again
first thousand people to use the link or
my code will get a free month of
skillshare
as we come back to the game ali reza
plays king b1 wants to make sure that he
doesn't have any sort of traps where
these pawns come off the board and the
rook can come down to a1 put a lot of
pressure on the king if it's on c1 so it
comes to b1 much safer square then pawn
b5 so black as we talked about doing a
good job of committing on the queen side
now you can tell he's probably going to
castle on the king side if he even
castles at all but knowing that there's
so much pressure
with this central control looks like
castling on the king's side is
definitely going to be the play but with
that said that means you need to start
throwing everything at the queen side of
the board see if you can attack the
white king on b1
since the bishop center attack comes
back to a2 you like to really still
control this long diagonal bobby fischer
used to do this a lot bring his bishop
back tuck it in here on a2 you still put
so much pressure on the f7 square your
opponent sometimes even forgets it's
there so it's something they always have
to be thinking about for the rest of the
game we do see castle on the king side
pawn pushing forward to g4 now this is
an interesting move
because after the pawn six pawn
exchanges then you can already see the
bishop takes on g4 now why would he
allow him to do that it's because of the
exchange that we're about to look at the
first move is knight to c6 now this is
threatening knight to e7 but it's much
more dangerous than that first you have
to understand what the risk is for black
if they were to take on d1 it's not just
that this is a bad exchange this is
actually checkmate so first let's look
at what that would look like knight
takes on e7 check and then it doesn't
matter if the king comes to h7 or h8
both of those are going to be checkmate
we'll look at h7 here and you can see
rook 2h1 there's no stopping it
bishop 2h5 will delay it for one move
but it is going to be checkmate always a
nice little
fun mate if you can find it
there's another video i've done on
mating patterns but the knight here on
e7 blocking off the g8 and the g6 square
and then getting your rook here on this
open file is a checkmate so that's what
black has to worry about
is not just giving up a bad exchange
it's actually losing the game so with
that
has to worry about the rook coming over
here to e1 with the check on e7 so plays
the move rook to e8
white plays rook to d5 centralizing the
rook and once the bishop is no longer
under attack because it's safe from this
rook here he does need to move his rook
because it's under attack from the
bishop on at g4
rook 2 c8 attacking the knight but now
that i can come to a7 it's pretty tricky
because once this rook moves then just
takes the pawn on b5
and now it's threatening the move knight
to c7 forking both the rooks one of the
rooks comes over to b8
knight to c7 the logical move but after
rook two a7 where does white move
kind of looked at the knight coming back
to b5 well that would just lose from the
rook here
and so it starts to look like this is a
tough spot
but this was calculated by ollie resin
this is why he's so good even at 18 as
he saw the move pawn e6
this is a discovered
defense with the bishop on f4 but it
also has so many other threats it's not
just the fact that he's now defending
the knight on c7 it's all the different
things that this also allows for white
to do and it's difficult for black as he
was looking at all these variations to
even come up with the fact that this was
so deadly let's look at some of the
options here if the pawn takes
okay well now the knight can take that
pawn
and you can see there's a discovered
attack with the bishop now attacking the
rook but this knight's also attacking
the knight on c5
there are so many threats that are
happening here it's difficult to deal
with and you also have to remember that
now this has opened up for this bishop
on a2 once this knight moves again and
the rook moves there's so many attacks
that the rook has it's a discovered
check with the king on g8 so there's so
many things that black has to do with
maybe the bishop takes on e6
bishop takes on b8 says yeah you can
take my rook i'm going to take yours
that's fine but i can first have a an in
between move so i can take here with
check i can take your rook there's just
so much to deal with maybe now they play
rook to a6
but now we have rook to f5 you can see
that the bishop can't take it
it's being pinned down by the bishop
here if they want to take that's fine if
you start to look at the material here
both sides
have a bishop but then you have two
rooks to a rook and a knight and white
has more pawns as well this is going to
be an in-game that should be very easy
for white to win
if you come back and say what if the
pawn doesn't take what if the bishop
takes okay well same thing then the rook
can come here to e5 that's one option
but i think it's just easier to play
knight takes on e6 same thing as before
you gobble up material you have a
discovered attack with your bishop on f4
and this is going to be extremely good
for
white so in the game we actually saw the
move rook to b7 says okay well i don't
have much option here i just have to aim
everything at my opponent's king that's
exactly what he does but then the move
pawn f7 check okay we'll first have to
get out of check king to f8
and then bishop to e5 so
always getting his material in the
center of the game attacking his
opponent you can see e5 does a good job
of defending on b2 but also attacks the
g2 or the g7 square
then we have
knight coming up to a d7 attacking the
bishop ali reza says you know what i
really like my bishop i think it's well
positioned so i'm going to go ahead and
exchange i'm going to give up my rook
because i'm all about
my position right here my bishops are
doing work you always hear about the
bishop pairs doing work and this is
exactly how it's done the bishop takes
on d7
and then the rook to h1 and in this spot
we do have black actually resign now if
you want to see how this play could
continue you can see bishop takes on a3
because you know the pawn can take it
would be pinned down
rook up to h8
maybe king 2 e e7 remember this pawn on
f7 is still defended by the bishop on a2
it's a nuisance to worry about this
bishop on a2 and now the sudden you have
this pawn on f7 that can promote it
sometime you have to always worry about
that that's going to be a pain to deal
with but you can't take it as well so
maybe knight to d5
check
the king moves the rook swings over
captures hey now there's an exchange
here and you can see just gobbling up so
much material
very very easy
game for white so that is ali reza that
was one of his games that he won
in the grand swiss tournament that
allowed him to go to the candace
tournament so 18 years old just
incredible that he's able to play like
this but hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video
definitely let me know what you think if
you want me to do a spotlight video on
all the other players in at the canis
tournament i think it'd be fun but
definitely want to make videos that you
guys want to
lastly reminder about our sponsor
skillshare if you click on the link in
the description below or use my code the
chess website they are giving the first
thousand people to do that one free
month to check it out but thank you
again so much for watching i'll see you
guys in the next video
you